hello ping and welcome to this video
play I like in okay probably a fan of
the real champion so I'm going to play
some entire Slav line here 6 hmm okay
good job try this line which i think is
interesting especially if black plays
Bishop d7 which is not the most precise
reply okay didn't happen so it seems
that he knew that this is a slightly
tricky respond specialty seven yeah here
Bishop d7 however is okay white against
the two bishops but the position is of
course extremely um solid for black okay
i wonder if i should try a four in this
position interesting interesting
question okay i'm trying this to prevent
e5 it's not the most intuitive move
let's say for them bishop on d to but II
five is very useful for black so I felt
I should prevent death for the time
being but ok black it certainly
certainly fine here yeah his reply was
good and against my against my sideline
okay i think i'm going to prevent Knight
to c4 and maybe I could have played
night a for you actually hmm it would
have been interesting directly trying to
exploit that Knight b6 possibility I
should have thought about this a little
bit longer hmm
okay night takes me five is stuff
obvious reply just one day this has some
kind of a drawback and I don't see it so
I'm taking a night a4 p.m. instead of b3
was probably strong yeah let's see what
is he doing here to continue night takes
b3e queen bee three looks very good for
white yeah maybe eight takes be five ok
something better I don't think so this
looks some quite promising I'm the I'm
them a porn up here
jan any account play 94 is probably what
he wants to do and it's difficult I mean
difficult to prevent Bishop d3 is a move
but it looks a bit passive maybe another
wave form after night before I would
like to preserve this bishop but yes got
this Bishop takes d4 IDM ok and maybe
just play a safe move he's happy to take
on d to know I guess for them for them
um opposite colored bishops and nope ok
yeah I think you should have taken
allowing me to keep the bishop am and
this position doesn't really help ok
this is this is an alternative but and I
still think you should have found should
take it on d tool if you take on c2 now
I'll keep the sea fowl
yeah what's next probably a five if he
allows it that's a good move I think but
maybe Queen to c5 here right I can take
on b5 maybe
still not still not totally easy he's
got rook c8 coming
it's not not totally easy 2595 can be
five rupee ages also still quite repair
quite decent resistance yeah I don't
know know what's best here okay going to
retreat but i'm not sure about this I
want to play a five this is why I went
to d2 yeah this is counter play but i
can also push my porn so look a for
maybe not sure i guess i have to check
hmm Oh to see and keep this now yes you
can check but I can go to g3 so I don't
quite pin see the the threat at the
moment Jack Quinn to d5 no its Lucas
hanging time money so I don't quite see
it rugby three I have this intermediate
check d525 threatening made myself that
looks strong right how to seem reply to
that see no move
yeah okay i can check twit with checks
IAM check a series of checks and now mmm
that doesn't seem to be a maid he
doesn't have fears one check on g2m ping
is that a perpetual it might be a
perpetual draw our third hmm now okay if
yes perpetual it's it's difficult now
for me to avoid rook g2 might be a draw
with Queenie to it is probably a draw
check check check check check check
check not sure that this is a drawing
hmm check check check that's it right no
chicks Queen g5 made your penis one
check one check on the six rang but
that's all I think check
checkmate I was a close call at the end
yeah so he um he wasn't totally okay
shape around here I think I already
missed knighted for him which looks
quite been quite annoying he only has
screen c7 I guess it's the only move and
after Luke c1 years to go back and well
I'm happy about this here probably um
yeah maybe slightly better but it's
nothing spectacular he has lost some
time with this stuff but black some
structure is super solid okay this this
yet this blonde at a pawn TM yeah this
was debatable I didn't want to do this
because Bishop d 4head check that that's
not good this is why I went here and I
know I think you should take on d to
this should be helpful for me however
okay you got that Bishop evade and this
is this is not term not totally
pointless even though I'm should be
better here it's not easy though here
the computer wants to play Bishop to f1
leading to the same position as as the
game and it wants to do this and this is
definitely an idea which is controlling
those squares and still keeping this
option open now that's probably better
here this is it's better for me but is
it winning is the question check Jim
Brooks you form can check the best seems
to be luke be three now and I looks if I
and Jack is ending okay yeah this is I
mean with absolutely perfect play maybe
a draw but he has to prove it and after
this I'm winning on 4chan and now we are
Queen g5 at f5 was winning and this is a
draw okay I wasn't sure but my clock was
down to 220 something seconds and okay
this is the wind with f5 threatening f6
checkmate and this is probably wedding
check check draw by stepping up here
okay no yank you can just save the king
yeah okay so check here it's a draw
check he probably can this is the move
that loses queen d 1 is the time when I
have to go back and this is actually I
was like oops so can I have to go back
then I shiny check that this is the drop
check check this way yeah I'm I'm
escaping check check check up to here
nice okay it win thanks for watching